tell me what happened yesterday what
were you doing when you heard the crash
it was just a crash I was actually
working Laura Bay and I seen the crash
just out of my heart I just went to help
her out so from what I understand and
I'm gonna have you explain it to me you
then were in that bottom Bay hopped out
and then ran and then ran over to the
car yes at the time I was working and I
came up for some fresh air seen that it
was a crash and went to go help out so
did was there concern on you guys part
because you saw smoke yes yes explain to
me what you saw I just seen a truck
under hit the car and just went to go
help and I seen the truck tipped over so
I just went over there to actually help
two people out of the car just want to
make sure they were safe when you got
over there and you were at the car when
you were when you got over there and you
were at the car tell me what you did
I asked one of my helpers one of my
basically upper bay employees and I
asked him to help me up on top of the
car and then I proceeded to guide
everybody out the car safely how were
they win because you had to pry the door
open what was it like once you pried
that door open and what did you see
inside after upright the door open I
just seen three people inside I just
immediately out of my instinct helped
him up helped him out of the car I was
just thinking about them at the time
Helen Hunt famous actress did you
recognize her as you pulled her out and
did you realize that you were helping a
Hollywood star I didn't know that I was
hoping a star my first instinct was just
get everybody all safe this out how once
you see a car flipped over like that how
violent did the accident look and how
scary was it at the moment I mean pretty
scary just didn't know if everybody was
okay and that's all I was thinking about
so did you reach in and pull them out or
how did you guide them out yeah I just
racing in I open the door reached in
helped everybody out and that was about
it
did they say anything to you before they
left or do they have a chance did you
have a chance to talk to them before
they left I didn't really have a chance
to talk to
but no buts about it I was just back and
forth made sure everybody was okay out
of both cars after today and you go home
and you realize that was that lady Helen
Hunt the actors when did you realize who
it was just now just now so I'm telling
you just now that it was the Helen Hunt
the an actress from Hollywood
yes she had no idea no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]